no bigger story in the ncaa tournament
so far
than oral roberts and the golden eagles
head coach paul mills
joining the rich eisen show right now
coach dan helly here
so happy to have you on i cannot tell
you
how crazy it was to see you guys
do what you did to get to the sweet 16
just the second
15 seed ever to make it this far
in the tournament and apparently it's
not a big surprise to you you've been
telling your guys all season long you're
gonna do this right
well dan one thank you uh for having me
on
uh two i think that you know anytime
that
you're competitive and you believe in
the people that you have
um you know you're you're trying to
have that mentality and instill that
confidence and not
phony confidence but i believe that our
players had put in the work
um i believe that that we were
competitive i mean
if you go look we played the third
toughest non-conference schedule in the
country
uh all five teams that we played in the
non-conference made the ncaa tournament
now we didn't win any of those games
lost by five to oklahoma state at osu
lost by five at wichita state
we were up 12 on arkansas in the second
half ended up losing that one
and so we knew that if we tightened up
some areas
on some really good teams that these are
two possessions that we need to make up
and i just felt over the course of time
the course of the year
that we would make those corrections and
to our guys credit
uh we've done that yeah i would say so
i'm just looking at your uh your twitter
page right now coach mills and i think
this sweet 16 run
deserves verification we're gonna have
to contact twitter
get that blue check mark for you uh i'm
sure that will be coming down the pipe
at any moment
right has to uh i know yeah i didn't
even know about
verification i have two teenage
daughters and
uh when i took the job here they said
your job's to get verified
and so i didn't even know what that
meant but uh honest to goodness it's uh
but i don't care anything about it
well i it's funny you say that about the
the the teenage daughters i have uh
a teenage son and daughter 13 and 14 and
yeah they get they get quite a kick out
of that they're like dad that doesn't
make any sense
that that that's important to uh to
teenage kids
what what has that been like for them to
watch this run for you guys
well it's it's great uh i mean
my kids have always been all in on
wherever we were
uh they do have different level of
shrills when other people
shoot free throws uh so so they can
change octave
levels based upon your free throw
percentage if you're bad they'll go a
little lower
if you're really good those drills will
get really higher so they've they've
been all in what's been tough is
you can't even touch him right you can't
even hug your wife you can't hug your
children
after after moments like ohio state and
and uh florida last night and so from
that context it's just
you gotta wave to them so uh they're old
enough to understand that
um i feel bad for some of our other
coaches who have
you know four-year-olds and
two-year-olds and and
they they want dad to lose uh for some
of our assistant coaches because they
want to see him and get him back home
but
that that's been tough obviously not
being able to share those moments with
your family
how do you keep your guys from from
getting too high
i mean you win that that first round
game against
second seeded ohio state and then you
come back against florida from
you know an 11-point deficit in the
second half
what does it say about these troops that
you just haven't believing
well one i if if you get too high you're
gonna lose
and and so if you like losing uh go
ahead and
the pay attention to all the hype and
read the social media
and return all the text messages uh if
you don't like losing
then get focused in on what's important
and there there will be a time to return
all these text messages
uh deal with all of these other issues
we're off actually
today and we'll be off tomorrow um in
order to
have these guys rest because we don't
play until saturday evening
but uh i mean you you have to turn the
page pretty quickly
i mean i heard a old football coach say
one time
uh you're a peacock one day and then
you're a feather duster tomorrow
and you realize just one how quickly
this thing can change
if you don't lock in on your
responsibilities and we have a very
mature group
and they've been able to do that you're
a peacock
one day and a feather duster the next
man i like that that is that is
penthouse to outhouse in a hurry uh dan
helly on the rich eigen show
filling in with paul mills the head
coach at oral roberts it is the
cinderella story
of the ncaa tournament this year what an
amazing run it has been for the golden
eagles they beat
ohio state then they beat florida just
the second
15 seed to ever make it to the sweet 16.
in the florida game you guys had that
intentional foul there about three
minutes to go
um kind of a risky move the analytics
said that it was a smart move was that
was that your idea you guys were down
one i believe at that point was that
your idea or do we need to give
credit to it to a really smart assistant
for that one yeah it's actually our
graduate assistant ian layman and
ian was at uh indiana and uh he and
sam patterson one of my assistant
coaches um
said hey 15 is six for 12. and i looked
over and i said
in the sec or on the year
and they said on the year and i said
we're following him
and so credit to to ian layman and coach
patterson
uh for for for bringing that up but we
were at the free throw line
shooting max was to to cut a three-point
deficit to one and we weren't able to
get stops
and so um we knew a play call that that
they were about to run and we knew that
that that guy was going to touch it
and fortunately it worked out for us
so explain to me the situation
with with dancing on campus because i'm
assuming some people are dancing a
little bit lately the way things have
been going for you
yeah i honestly don't know i i mean i
doubt there
and i've heard people say there's a
prohibition against dancing
uh the the president asked me to dance
after we went to the conference
tournament so surely that's not a policy
the president is encouraging it uh but i
i
do like the whole idea it's not as if
you could ever stop kids from dancing i
don't even think that's uh
possible i know baylor uh when i was
there i think they had a policy
uh way back in the 1980s i'm sure at
some point
a number of uh christian universities
may have had
certain things in place that that they
realize now
uh may not be the case that you can kind
of put limits on people
but uh i i was glad to see we
had a number of people in the maybe
center where we play
and it wasn't socially distanced uh
but but it's it's good to see kind of
people
lose their mind for a little bit because
over the course of the past year
obviously we
everybody has done their best to stay
away and and to have an event that could
just kind of bring people together for
even just a brief moment uh is pretty
cool
dan helly filling in on the rich eisen
show talking to paul mills head coach of
oral roberts it is
by far you know the best story of the
ncaa tournament so far and there are a
lot of great ones out there
right now coach you talked about keeping
the kids off social media we don't need
to answer all the text messages
is that even possible and is that
something you really say to hey let's
just put the phones down
for a while um one it is possible
i mean it isn't as if you can't do it um
two uh that there's a time and a place
for it right
um i mean i as i told them talk to your
mom talk to your dad
uh talk to your girlfriend um but i mean
that nobody's gonna think you're rude
because you're focused in on your
responsibility
and and i do think that um probably
your more mature players uh know how to
handle that kind of thing
and and maybe some younger guys don't
but
i i can assure you that that what our
guys enjoy
is winning and being together and in
order for those things to happen you do
have to avoid distractions you talked
about some of your leaders max a smith
and kevin o'banner
have been absolute stallions for you in
this tournament i i
i don't know that i've seen two guys
have back-to-back games as good as
they've had
in a long time um how much do you lean
on
on these two well they're the best duo
in the country
scoring wise max is obviously the
leading scorer in the country and then
when you look at kevin and his
contributions there's no other team who
has a duo
um like we do and and people
know that right um and so with
it it's one thing to perform when you're
not a focus of a defense it's a
different
element to do it when you are but
they're also the two best in the country
in my mind did middle pick and roll
and so uh we put those guys in a ton of
different
middle pick-and-roll situations and max
is making the right read
kevin is making the right read and and
they're doing a phenomenal job of just
this is actually the best play we talk a
lot about
we're not here to get a good shot we're
here to get a great shot
and and they understand what their
strengths are and
do terrific work in middle pick and roll
especially with all of the coverages
that we've seen through the course of
the year because
and we've we've seen it all from
trapping to switching
uh regardless of what it is we've kind
of seen all the elements and
they've they've handled all this stuff
really well they've been fantastic
what are you doing for the next couple
of days obviously you're pre you're
practicing you're hanging out but during
the day
when you're not on the practice floor
what are you guys doing as a team how
much time do these players get on their
own are they hanging out in the room
because there's
you're not going anywhere yeah yeah
unfortunately we haven't
breathed any indianapolis air you're
just breathing air conditioning the
whole time
uh so we're trying to find a way to get
a kickball game in
uh the baseball field that they're
allowing us to
get across so uh i got to make sure i
stretch i don't want to pull a hamstring
or anything you're going to play in the
game
oh yeah absolutely absolutely
we'll probably do staff versus players
now the good thing is i've got about a
hundred graduate assistants and student
managers so we can outnumber them by
quite a bit and uh make sure everybody's
in the field
we'll lose it athletically but we're
just trying to breathe fresh air right
now
and the reality is is our guys have
school work to do
and they've got a responsibility there
and so
they've got tutoring via zoom they've
got classes via zoom
and so they have responsibilities uh as
a student as well
and then you're covet testing every day
oh you're watching film
and so uh we we keep them busy we don't
let them just get to their own right
uh there is about a two hour period
where they're playing
a number of card games and and 2k on ps5
uh so so there is a break you brought up
school i almost forgot that they had to
take classes
you got yes
yeah that's wild so you guys have you
have arkansas coming up next you played
them before right in december
played them in december and and they
acemus had an uncharacteristic game for
him just 11 points what what did you
learn
uh from playing the razorbacks in that
game one we're a different
team than what we were um we got up 12
um at the half or we were up 10 at the
half got up 12
early and and then they basically
turned up their offensive rebound and
transition game
and we didn't do well the one thing that
did happen in that game was
um max max we would kind of one of our
other players
we would kind of move them both on the
ball and off the ball
um whereas we're way different now than
what we were
then simply because the ball is in max's
hand about 99.99
of the time now and so uh and so from
that i just think the decision making
since that
course of the game we we've become a
different team and it's obviously played
out really well for us
i'm looking at your uh schedule here
and you had yet what one
two three three games canceled couple
postponed
um we had one against uh we had one
conference
uh that was scheduled and then we had
one other non-conference game
um that got delayed for a week
so we literally only had one game that
we had to miss all year on the counter
covet
so you played nearly a full schedule
which is not the case you didn't have
any issues with code this year our team
so we we've been very fortunate
well that is that's outstanding and i
guess you're very fortunate now too
because
when you punch your name into google one
of the first things that pops up is your
quote about being able to do laundry now
is that something you've got have you
done the laundry yet uh you know what
they
came by so we got back i don't know
midnight last night and about one
o'clock
they gave us a bag and then they said
hey it has to be out at nine
and by one i had the bag full and was
sitting outside my door
and somebody was kind enough to come
grab it they came by last night and just
grabbed our laundry so
i think they said it'd be ready at some
time around two o'clock today
and and that is a good thing um because
literally out of close well
you got to be careful during that
kickball game right yeah
yeah uh so so uh they told us
hey pack for seven to ten days and then
there'll be laundry being able to do so
and we've literally we got here last
saturday so today's monday
so i packed for right around that number
so it's it's good now to uh
to get hey everything's fresh and clean
here we go we can start right back over
i love it i love it you're playing with
how it's money right now paul
obviously do you allow i promise you we
don't think that way
do you allow yourself to look ahead at
all to
to what what could be next if you
advance
um to baylor villanova yep i only
know that because i talked to scott drew
this morning and
he's like you know we're on the same
side of the bracket i had no idea
i honestly didn't know who we were
supposed to play after this one
i was like who are we playing next and
they were the texas tech
uh arkansas winner and i was like oh
okay
uh but honest to goodness i had no idea
i i did vaguely know that that baylor
was in the south but it's not anything
that you ever paid attention to
so uh but no uh we i i can assure you
all our attention will uh will be on
arkansas
this is gonna change the life of
everybody involved with
with oral roberts basketball program but
but perhaps
nobody more than you down the road is
that something that's crept into your
mind
in what context well there's just
there's opportunities doors open when
you guys do what you've done
andy enfield the last coach to do that
at florida gulf coast is you know is
is now at usc just in general well it
could be book deals it could be anything
this is a big big deal
is that it's something when as you're
sitting around and you're doing your
laundry that you allow to creep into
your head
well i i will say this my only desire
ever um i love the movie hoosiers right
i've seen it
well over a thousand times um
and all i wanted to do was be a really
good high school coach because i just
love the high school environment i love
that investment
what i realized in my six years of
coaching high school
was man these guys not that you expect
them to love it as much as you
but i'd have one or two guys who loved
it as much as me
so when i went to college i was like all
right you're gonna be around
guys who enjoy it and that's what
i'm able to do and so from that context
i mean i i'm doing exactly what i'm
called to do
and that is investing in the lives of
these 18 to 22 year olds
at a place that i believe in
in the mission of of investing
in young men and and can do it in a way
and so
i mean i wake up every single day
excited uh not only to recruit for oru
but to invest in our players here so uh
i i i'm glad that our players get this
experience
and and i hope it's even more i mean
when i took the job honest to goodness
um i talked about being in final fours
and you've seen it with gonzaga you've
seen it with butler you've seen it with
loyola chicago
seen it with george mason um you've seen
it with vcu you've seen it with wichita
state you've seen a number of mid majors
do that
and i think those are the things that
make college basketball so exciting
and i honestly believe we can do it here
at oru
and why not oral roberts what a run it
has been so far
hey coach i really appreciate the time
we kept you a little longer than i
expected uh
the entire nation all 49 states besides
arkansas i think are rooting for you
guys
so well good thanks dan good luck coming
up uh again appreciate the time glad you
have some clean laundry and please be
careful do not pull a hamstring in that
kickball game leave it to the young
criticism i agree yeah
so if i'm limping on a saturday night
you'll know why
you're the man good luck coach thank you
thank you that's paul mills from
oral roberts university getting ready to
play arkansas coming up here in a few
days a 15
seed just the second ever in
the sweet 16. hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here